introducing the new Leonberger I am
beyond excited that's pretty bad
that's the freaking cold open a it's a
coal open there today we're going to
find the best drive-through veggie
burger oh I've been looking for a good
meat replacement cheeseburger for like
two years now and impossible burger and
Beyond burger are like the best I've had
am i you are not finished I am NOT but
listen I love food hungry wat freakin
hungry Carl's jr. now has a beyond
burger see we're going to be gone burger
gonna eat some fries I'm a vegetarian
I'm not high but I'm gonna like the food
and I'm gonna eat it all cuz I'm hungry
right now and we're gonna have a battle
where I was Junior we made it that looks
pretty frickin good oh yes if I were
really in the mood for a cheeseburger
I would totally drive to Carl's jr. to
buy this it's also like less heavy
obviously I like this a lot
yeah this is pretty good I'd get this
and I'm not vegetarian how much is this
it was six dollars very it's that's like
a revelation like to have a meatless
burger for six dollars so many more
people can buy it now next up is
actually my go-to veggie burger the
burger king the Morningstar whopper I
have a little experience with
Morningstar products so I'm excited so
this one is the gist of burgers $4
I don't like this at all carrot oh my
god no it's kind of spicy you were
choosing bizarre I do not like this
there's no flavor even the sauce is like
trying to give it a little kick and it's
like hard in some places that's the
thing about veggie burgers people are
always complaining about the texture
which I understand and on the good
beyond burger it was like really
surprising good it was smooth seamless
and this literally has a seam this could
fool me as chicken maybe like if you
said it was like a chicken patty see
that I don't think I'd order it again
the textures come weird it's a little
dry overall not the worst veggie burger
I've ever had I just don't know about
your palate Matt cuz you raved about
this do you just like eating bland
things normally I get it with cheese I
also get with mustard he just said the
word mustard so I think that really just
discredited him you're about to go
against mustard oh yeah you'll like my
shirt oh man I'm coming from the
perspective of someone who loves the
taste of meat and misses it and wants a
replacement but there are lots of
vegetarians and vegans who really don't
like the taste of meat and in that case
this could be a very good alternative
what's the next one I know I need one to
replace that we need some inspiration
please the third place that we chose
White Castle has a brand new impossible
burger well we don't have any white
castles in California and I didn't know
that so we're going to a very California
place fat burger who also has the
impossible burger what's going to
Fatburger to eat the impossible burger
it doesn't have any meat that was pretty
good what do you guys know about fat
burger I just had fat burger the other
day the fries are amazing but I've never
had the impossible burger there
do not have a drive-through so I have to
get out of the car fat burgers alrighty
it was also very expensive was it what
do you know what this better be the
Cadillac of that burger baby this is it
chief this is it what is it it the
flavor hits you from the taste buds
it's like wake up I don't know the meat
kind of tastes like in and out meat a
little bit mmm is this real though it
tastes real what if it's real I don't
like it what why what good could have
been the other two burgers I ate before
him
I'd like I didn't even eat those burgers
look I'm tasting this on an empty
stomach it was okay we're headed back to
the office we've eaten the beyond burger
from Carl's jr. the Morningstar burger
from Burger King and the impossible
burger from Carl's jr. what did you hey
listen Carl's jr. was poppin Burger King
was not poppin fat burger popped the
[ __ ] I think Carlos jr. pop-lock and
dropped it and then Morningstar just
dropped it yeah and then fat burger and
possible burger picked it back up again
and reversed it and reverse it in my
books cause jr. definitely won I think
the best meat was fat burger but the
toppings and the way the burger came
together it was the best one in my face
the other ones just I don't know what
they were doing Burger King is in a
phone category I'm gonna go ahead give a
big shout out to my man Burger King the
Burger King for being the first one to
even dip their toe in the frickin veggie
burger game I gotta give Big Ups to that
I'm gonna go get a B on burger from
Carl's jr. maybe tonight I'll get the
Carl's jr. for sure I'm Megan I'm full
of burgers I'm Maya and I am also back
thanks for watching
[Music]